LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to Coffee with a Googler.
Today I'm going to be chatting
with Kelsey Hightower, who's
a developer advocate
on our cloud platform.
Now Kelsey gets to work
with cloud, and Kubernetes,
and containers, and all
this kind of cool stuff.
So Kelsey, tell us all about it.
What is it that you do?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yes,
so my role here at Google
is a staff developer advocate.
And I focus on things
like containers, docker,
micro services, and 12 factor,
all backed by Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes is kind of
the anchor point where
we help developers
understand how
to adapt some of these patterns
to run their applications
in the cloud.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now say I've been
out of software development
for the past couple of years,
and I haven't heard
of containers,
or any of this kind of stuff.
What exactly is a container?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Yes, I think people
that have been out of
technology for a long time
and they see a mobile device
where you can push a button
and your application
shows up, I think
this is what's happening on the
server side for applications.
You know, no matter what
languages you're writing in,
you can take that
language, that application,
packaged it into this
container, and run it
on any cloud provider or your
laptop in very similar ways.
So I think the game's
changed dramatically
for how people build
and ship applications,
on the cloud and distributed
systems, in general.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now, that's cool,
but where do you see this going,
say, in the next year or two?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: With
cloud, the promise
was that you would be able to
run your applications anywhere.
You would just
burst out and scale.
So I think what
Kubernetes brings
to the table, and
containers underlying that,
is the ability for you to
actually do that anywhere.
You can pick the cloud
platform of your choice,
on your local laptop, in
your local environment.
So we're starting to get to a
real application portability.
You write your application.
And you can choose your target,
no matter where you live,
what region, what
cloud provider.
And Kubernetes is doing this
all out in the open, open source
project, with tons of
people in our community
making that possible
wherever you want to.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now Kubernetes, this
is pretty popular on
open source, right?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yes, so
one of the amazing things
about Kubernetes, it's an
extremely popular project
mainly because it's
open source, number one,
but it also bakes in a lot
of the learnings from Google
and some of our other partners,
like CoreOS and Red Hat.
And they've all come together.
And we collaborated on this
very popular project on GitHub.
So Kubernetes has
become this anchor point
for distributed systems and
container management, at scale.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
you're seeing this openness
of container standards
as being something
that's super important
in the enterprise, right?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So I think
the enterprise, in general,
is really fixed on
having an open platform.
Because let's face
it, they don't
want to get locked in again.
Right?
Once you get locked into
a particular vendor,
you're pretty much stuck there.
So the open source movement,
maybe started years ago,
has offered a way
for their enterprise
to not only select a
partner in technology,
but also to participate.
So Kubernetes gives
the enterprise
the ability to participate
and shape the future
that they want to see.
And we see this with
very popular companies
like eBay, AT&T--
all of these companies
are using Kubernetes,
and also contributing
to Kubernetes
in a way that allows
their enterprise
to adopt their own
workloads into the platform.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, I mean I've
built applications in the past.
And I know that
dependency management
can be an absolute nightmare.
So containers are
something that you
think could really, really
help me with that, right?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Yes, so that's a goal.
So containers attempt to push
the dependency management
to the developer.
You're building the app.
You know what your
dependencies are.
So given a container
platform, you
have the opportunity to package
your application from end
to end, and just turn
over the box to the team
to run it on the platform.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, I
understand that this can also
go beyond enterprise, and
games such as Pokemon Go
have been using this.
Do you have any other examples
of how people have used it?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Also,
I think Pokemon Go
is a good example of using
something like Kubernetes.
Right?
The goal is to make a game that
people can play and not manage
infrastructure.
So for a company, in this
case, for a Pokemon Go,
you throw your game
back into a container,
and you allow Google
Cloud Platform just
to scale it across as many
machines as your users demand.
So this is like the perfect
use case where you just
want to write an application,
get it in front of people,
and let the platform do the
heavy lifting of scaling
and responding to users.
LAURENCE MORONEY: This
all sounds really good.
And if I'm a developer,
you've just really inspired me
to get started with
this kind of stuff.
So where should I go, and
what should I do to get going?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: You
have tons of options.
One option is to
grab your laptop.
All that extra memory,
all that extra CPU,
you can download a
project called MINICUBE.
It's an open source product
that gives you a single node
Kubernetes cluster.
And that will give
you all the primitives
you need to exercise Kubernetes,
deploy your application.
And the nice thing
about that investment,
you can take all of those
configs, your applications that
are packaged and containers,
and push them up to GKE,
our hosted Kubernetes
environment
on Google Cloud Platform.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So Kelsey, do you
have any advice
for developers who
are interested in
Kubernetes and who
are interested in cloud
and all that kind of stuff?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I
think the best thing
to do is go visit
Google Cloud Platform
and click the GKE button.
And what it will do
is, in a single button,
you can get a fully
working Kubernetes cluster,
like the same one that
Pokemon Go was using.
And then you can
ramp up really quick.
So you can start
out with three nodes
and scale up to thousands
of nodes as the time comes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: What
does GKE stand for?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Google Container Engine.
We wanted GCE for
Google Container Engine,
but that was already taken
by Google Compute Engine.
So the K stands for Kubernetes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And if
you want to get started,
don't forget we've got a bunch
of links in the description
below.
Go take a look at them.
Kelsey shared them with us.
And there's some
great stuff there.
I can't wait to see
what you build in cloud.
I can't wait to see what
you do with containers.
If you've any questions,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
Don't forget to hit
that Subscribe button.
Thank you.